[Music]
this is
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby
what's up daddy wow new intro whoa
and we got we're people trained we've
changed we're wearing white shirts
white t-shirts my guys white shirts my i
noticed that my body hasn't changed no
for the years we looked exactly the same
here's what a [ __ ] your lids are
different my lids are different your
hair is different but i this is my
favorite thing ray longo comes to my
show in in jersey and one of his black
belts and matt sarah black belt who's
about my age goes
i'm i'm so [ __ ] lame he goes how do
you move like that your body is so fluid
i was like
that's the greatest guy
because i'm made of water bro cause i'm
[ __ ] mercury dude how about that
going through all the old school sets
that we've had we've had some sets we've
got some sets these have some sets yeah
and then how about yesterday i ran into
our boy who was our boss at fox sports
good guy great guy i can't remember his
name the best so he i was at uh malibu
cars and coffee with my boys
and then he pulled up in a like a 2002
ferrari like where'd you get this i
haven't seen him in years since fox when
did you hit this he's like yeah i just
got about so he's like i'll park we'll
talk i'm like yeah so he gets out and
he's like man his friend was there who
doesn't know us or anything about that
and he goes oh what are you doing he
goes uh we did fine kid 3d man he's
explained 3d i go man and he was what
happened to those fox says all of them
man he was they do yeah i wish we could
get him and like redistribute him now on
our youtube he goes
i'll make that happen like it's not like
fox has got this it's in a vault and
we're saving that's what he said he goes
they're not using them they don't he
goes they also they never cared about it
because romero's the only one that
really supported you guys there he goes
they don't care no they're not they're
doing nothing with them right i was like
it's not even like their genre like what
they're trying to do like give them to
us i said i'll pay for me is let's see
just let me reach out to him i think
shanks or something's still the head guy
there yeah good wouldn't that be great
if we get those fire kit 3ds back get
them out there yeah put them on our
youtube let people finally see them
so much fun dude we did that with no
money oh that's eric shanks is that him
yeah yep you still have fox sports yeah
man that's great i really need those
firing kit 3ds he's a good man yeah
he'll be fun right yeah be [ __ ]
awesome how was uh dc he was [ __ ] the
nation's capital dude i went i i was
interesting as i go to the capitol i
went to college there and you know what
i realized americans how far outside
like
oh like the main stuff like uh like 10
minutes you know it's all about an
amazing area i love dc dude you realize
like how how amazing this country is
with all its warts and it's issues like
did you say warts yeah warts
warts and all yeah you know the idea
you've never heard that expression no no
so whenever you say that whenever you
say like uh this company is a great
company warts and all you got you got
some awards yeah a few spots
words are disgusting yeah
i've never heard that term it's very
aggressive words are yeah listen man i
love america sure we have our warts like
if you had uh you know like i don't like
yeah like imagine if someone's like oh
how's your girl like she's good man i
mean you know she has a reward we're
good she's got a couple i'm gonna start
adding that into my vocabulary he's got
some anal warts dude how's the how's
fire kid going at you and brian dude
we're good i mean we have our awards but
you know it's do you know you can get
out most people like yeah brian has
warts like yeah yeah everyone has i have
words brian has words you know you can
get anal warts do you know this yeah
genital warts no you can also get anal
warts
and i sometimes i i have a story and i
keep it to myself just go ahead and keep
it to yourself yeah it's about anal
warts you don't want it yeah we don't
want to kick that off well anal warts is
a good way to ruin if you're eating
anything and somebody goes man i had
some i had some anal warts removed you
go dude but i'm gonna start using warts
for everything i can't eat now when i go
over your house for dinner your girls
are like how was there i'm like it was
good had a dwart
hats warts i'm calling my special anal
warts that's all i was going to say a
new name for your special i don't care
anal warts live anal warts live is a
good idea
brian callan anal warts dude it's just a
red a red [ __ ] eye with just a bunch
of warts just dots yeah
whatever you do if you're listening to
this do not google anal warts because
it'll ruin your day it'll change your
life yeah you could either do that or if
you really want to ruin your day just do
isis be hidden yeah i feel the exact
same my my buddy my buddy told me in
college he goes i had a i had genital
warts and i was like
i didn't know what the [ __ ] that was and
i made the mistake of seeing a picture
of genital warts it'll ruin your day and
i was like that's all i thought about i
was like i would die if i were also
something you can't just get rid of
like they're there forever no no you
well you have them removed i guess yeah
but i think but it's a virus yeah yeah
oh yeah keeps on keeping on well now
that you know that's why they have a
vaccine
for anal for general wars because they
can turn in women especially they can
turn cancerous there's a vaccine for
anal warts there's a vaccine for a
genitals do kids have to get it what if
fatching started pushing anal warfare
most girls don't get the vaccine oh
interesting yes and there has to be a
term not called anal wart prevention
it's called genital warts and i think
that when they
when they make their way to your taint
and your your bum hole you've been
you've been doing some pretty [ __ ] even
though it wasn't really ashamed it's
time to chill out girl time hey that hot
girl summer very cool yeah you got a fun
summer yep but in that summer you got
warts yeah how was your summer it was
good some awards here and there's a
couple of some words dude i'm going to
use it all the time people are like how
is brian special i actually enjoy
there's some warts though yeah now i
went in to uh i went into the i was at
the capitol and i went and interviewed
uh dan crenshaw who was the navy seal
with the eye patch yep and smart kid
they're smart and then there's him like
like when you ask him a question he'll
give you a one-hour answer he went to
harvard graduate school navy seal and
then goes i'm going to go might get my
politician yeah i'm going to go get my
[ __ ] from tufts and then i'm gonna
harvard john f kennedy school of
government get my master's in that
and when you talk to a guy like that
like i'm pretty versed in some history
and and
compared someone has their black belt in
it though no sir no and and he he is a
very smart guy but what's funny about
when you get into like what you think is
politics versus what actually politics
is like just the nitty gritty [ __ ] that
you deal with on a daily basis
and by the way who wants to do that
whites you see some
i mean dc's got some
whites like white i'm white man dc's
pretty freaking very black yes no no
very black i went to college that's your
crowd though yeah very black
but when you go to the powers like the
like you go into the capitol oh yeah
especially the republican side it is
true it's oh and you have to go there
why did you interview interview dan
crenshaw
yeah i went and interviewed that
i asked him who he thinks he could fight
who he'd have his hands full when he
looks out on
on the floor during congress oh who's
going to beat him up
there's there's a one guy who's an mma
fighter who's a congressman who is a
professional in mma oh
i can't remember his name i think you
would know him uh there are a couple a
couple of there are a lot of special
forces operators jesse ventura was the
navy seal that guy i'm putting my money
on over damn boy dan's a lot younger
dan's younger dan's younger dan daniel
now but where's this interview live on
uh i'll tell you about that i'll i'll
let you know i've got some plans for it
okay i'm doing i'm doing a bunch of
stuff you just started banking what i'm
doing is i'm going out every time i go
to a town i'm i'm doing something called
best of and i'm basically coming for the
best of dc yeah i'm just the best of
whatever the town has to offer that's
cool i think i'm going to go python
hunting and uh so in florida there's all
sorts of [ __ ] you can do so west palm
beach i'm going to be there dude do
ugliest person florida
wait that's actually such a sick idea
because i'm just footballing ideas here
well the ugliest human in florida and
people were like well they're a human
being like yeah they live in the swamp i
hate only i hate it
you know me i don't like making fun of
people for their it's an award
yeah it's like winning a contest
well
i i was thinking about this so i go to
the town so west palm beach i'm going to
go about an hour up i can find pythons
now when you get a python they're such
an invasive species 300 bucks for a male
500 for a female if it's got eggs so you
got people out there
making 10 grand a week just getting
pythons because they're everywhere tough
gig tough cake yeah tough gig but uh
i want to go find out i want to they say
they have nile crocodiles out there yeah
i'm for this real quick so to me you and
your white shirt and sandals in the uh
everglades in a fan boat and a fan boat
by yourself or you're going to hire
people you gotta have an expert yeah i
got an expert i might do some noodling
you know when you catch the with you
yeah catfish i'm scared of that so
hannah baron's like the best in the
world you're on a bear right right no
can't hear you oh my god i can't pay you
don't even ask not going to connect you
guys that's my friend hannah bear come
on don't be standing with yourself he's
gorgeous yeah super gorgeous and she's
like the best uh
cats and she loves the shows too so
she's like she shows yeah hannah hit me
up
oh my god i hadn't done the size of that
[ __ ]
they're enormous oh my god that's six
pounds wait a minute
well she's she's [ __ ] gorgeous yeah
yeah yeah she was on king of the sting
we had a wait
song she's about a hunter oh yeah she
does everything yeah all outdoor stuff
see that stingray not today stingray
what a woman yeah who who who's married
to her she's she might have a boy
she brought her boyfriend to zany's does
that guy does that guy go to church
every day and thank god oh yeah yeah
yeah she's yeah she's a cutie i mean
she's not just a cutie she's a [ __ ]
tongue in her accent right her accent
she talks and she's she called a
dinosaur
she's got a t-rex there so that's cool
dude what the [ __ ] is going on with that
i can't believe you've never looked at
how hot she is yeah just
a giant slimy fish on my [ __ ]
shoulder she's eating that thing yeah
she's a bee she's tiny too yeah she's
not big yeah that catfish is you know
she puts her she's elbow deep in these
catfish oh my god shooting guns killing
him she's in she's in some
shape
yeah that is going to be all the papa
yeah she's the best nicest lady ever too
super super getting that tattoo
that'd be cool no just get the big
catfish on your back as a tap but hey
spit on ideas so the anaconda thing all
that stuff cool yeah dude
dude do the richest [ __ ] in palm
beach well now i'm on the search for the
biggest dick in palm beach
that'd be such a that'd be a very
crowded field
it's a crowded field what if you what
you wanna when you go there do you want
ratings or none yeah there's money and
then there's money and that would be
naples and west palm beach right
and you guys really went you got some
old crusty
yup old crusty guys with some the
biggest [ __ ] in west palm beach
and you just find them
just find them yeah you have like a
criteria like the richest guy in the
world like the richard what would that
be just the richest most but like the
guy who's got who's got a gold rolls
royce although those guys usually don't
have money
no right yeah the guys all that money
aren't they might have a royals royce
but they're not showing off like that
what'd you say you say royals rice rolls
yeah you say that and you better get it
right it's the one thing that bothers me
what would it say for me we've been
doing this podcast for 27 years and the
one thing i will never [ __ ] live down
it makes me wait
i want goals
rolls-royce you're into cars
say it right not rolls royces though say
rolls-royce rolls-royce is not my thing
don't say royals royce you know how i'm
not an [ __ ]
i don't know how to say rolls-royce i
don't care there you go i don't care
that's lesson one
that's lesson one now you go there you
find an [ __ ] you go how do you sell
how do you say this car's name no see
how they say it nope and if they say it
too well and elegant no [ __ ] number
one you can say royals like they're
rolls royces so say that
right now rolls royce yeah
yeah
coming from
the prius and the biggest [ __ ] tesla on
the planet hey so that's why i don't
care so i'm going to say
hello hey right i do play but i do miss
my big tesla yeah but right yeah right
yeah
no one respects me in my little white
house oh i lost all the respect for you
i got it i didn't tell you this i get i
know all this every day i get moved off
the road oh yeah i swear to god women
are like get the [ __ ] out of the way i'm
like jesus you notice the logo for the
woke movement yeah it's your car it's
you and your car i should have drifted
it's the logo yeah you get that on the
hat it says stay woke and has your car
on it
then the back says i only eat soy i
don't i only eat soy yeah yeah well you
know this though right i do
i love it what gave it away when it came
with soy protein
i just don't like the fact that i have
to have my phone's app on to open the
doors or it comes with a credit card
that i have to hold it drives me nuts
man oh that's the way you get in yeah
and the [ __ ] handles like they i i
actually have a problem with the car
that's too much i bought it maybe i'll
sell it you want to buy a tesla
i'll buy and set it on fire
no listen man i'll buy it and drive it
off the pca it's good you can just i
don't want to be in it i'll just
it's fast
sure yeah i mean it's got some kick not
really though huh it got kick no he's
got kick
because you know it's the most
unreliable car in america you know what
it's not true old
i don't know bring it up chin that's
horrible reliable it's the most track
yeah no road and track gave it the most
reliable
what is this tesla test is actually the
most reliable
you'll see
10 most unreliable watch this tesla
won't even be close to it watch this
watch this ready
volvo
go on you'll see you're you're wrong
whoever told you this is hilarious
ecosport of course keep going oh we got
the jeep wrangler of course
tesla number seven that's tesla model s
oh no oh you oh you don't know you don't
know that they have horrible problems oh
that's funny that's funny yeah yeah you
said they're not gonna be on the list
now there's gonna be multiple
versions of that car on this list yeah
i've never heard of this colorado it's a
it's a [ __ ] it's a small no that's
this this is this is people who are
against electric cars this is not
unbelievable no no there was a new york
post it was it was
cheap compass all right well what a jeep
yeah
a lot of volkswagen a lot of jeeps a lot
of tesla
subaru i would not think subaru but
that's that weird one
wow number one
chevrolet silverado now a caveat to
being the most unreliable remember how
many chevy silverados are how many
teslas there are because so they're
gonna have more numbers but tesla's not
known as a reliable car well i thought
the s was uh
you know got
glowing i've never had a problem at all
i've never taken a shot once i know so
many people with problems really oh yeah
the only thing i hear about that what
now i'm sure now again there's so many
of them
you're gonna have more you know yeah but
yeah yeah i've heard so many issues i'm
so lazy man if i can get an electric car
with that kind of speed because daddy
likes some speed now you know no that
you you don't care that's the thing i
don't care no i don't care at all as
long as you can get from point a to
point b especially where you're coming
from who cares yeah it's true yeah yeah
he looks gay yeah who cares dude
so what basically i am a gay man and
it's white with white interior you wear
that white shirt yeah hell yeah yeah
yeah i like you just look like a red
thumb drive down the road i just don't i
don't like being a target i don't i've
always avoided conflict with like guys
in bars because they just look at me and
go i don't think that guy's gonna be it
i'm sorry wait are you saying you don't
drive a cool car because you want to
avoid conflict yeah because otherwise i
got like street fighting oh yeah you
know what i mean yeah i got to get down
yeah i don't know that makes sense while
you're driving when i i i i don't like
the conflict let me get let me get
something that's a easy car because
people that drive nice cars have been so
many fights yeah you're getting fights
yeah if you go on world star and you see
the the car fights
ferrari people
have a problem not if you have
cauliflower ears
i've never had 60 pounds
i've never never heard that that's made
up no no no
not a dude
if you're in a ferrari people like what
a dick and they they [ __ ] with you i
don't think there's more of a tesla
thing now might be yeah because i was
with my daughter because now everyone
drives home i'm with my kids
you and i i didn't even realize i cut
him off anyways you and your f word
tesla f
[ __ ] like just and i was like and i
turned and i looked at him he was in the
truck and i was like
on principal i i should engage here and
my daughter
goes dad we're in a tesla don't respond
smart with that my daughter smart gal
and she was
i don't know 11 at the time 12. smart i
mean part of the main pros cons there
yeah pros and cons but i did a slow turn
yeah and this one you had the big boy
test that's kind of the big one not even
the small and it was a gray it was
midnight blue or something the night
yeah graph graphite
i went white and white but uh dan
crenshaw was cool cool [ __ ]
just very smart i mean
when you talk to a guy like that he he
he's a guy who
he may be a republican but he's
primarily feels like very in the middle
because he's very thoughtful about
things right he's very
definitely a republican though yeah but
if you ask him a question
he's got a he said something really cool
about government
he's like it's not that big government's
the problem it's how much does
government affect your individual life
and freedom sure so you may need a big
bureaucracy to run [ __ ] but the real
question is you don't want it in your
life you don't you don't want it like
like restricting your [ __ ] everyday
life that's the problem yeah yeah did
you ask him about the mass shooting in
buffalo did that happen we didn't get
into that i think it happened the next
day oh gosh that guy somebody that guy
[ __ ] uh live streamed it and i saw it
the first two minutes
yeah then twitch took it down somebody
sent it to me and i was i didn't know
what it was by somebody you mean you
searched for it no i did not i swear to
god i didn't somebody sent it to me and
i didn't realize that i don't know i
don't like that [ __ ] what friend was
like
ruined my whole [ __ ] money yeah what
friend like check this live stream of a
mass shooting i can't see that [ __ ] it
just makes me so sad and so scared and
so [ __ ] depressed but um it was like
a video game looked like a [ __ ] video
game you know yeah it's like jesus
christ yeah i saw it
you didn't see it yeah yeah it was on
world star so you see what's happening
here that's
you you keep watching world star that's
why yes damn roster yeah yeah i wouldn't
want that seems to i don't like seeing
well absolutely not i don't like
watching the twitch should get down
first two minutes yeah yeah only two
minutes but jesus christ
yeah you keeping up with the amber heard
johnny depp thing it came right back
today i said that's the best fight going
on right now because pfc is kind of low
to their next big pay-per-view the best
fight is amber heard
yes i guess she was talking about the
[ __ ] she was saying how it's the dog it
was the dogs
hmm dogs
deb's dog ate some weed
this is so humiliating
to have to talk about like no it wasn't
my [ __ ] my shit's not that big like you
know i
i mean how yeah it's just like all the
[ __ ] is coming out no punishment but all
the [ __ ] is coming out on both of them
yeah whether you're just like oh you're
both crazy yeah although i think she
definitely lied through her teeth oh my
god yes he just sounds like he's a
nightmare because he drinks and drugs a
lot and just becomes this [ __ ] can i
interject because i've been paying
attention to a lot of the stuff
especially both
so obviously and i've heard that before
they go
um both sides look really bad the main
difference is
it's the details of johnny depp's
addiction that are coming out which are
unflattering but sympathetic because you
hear it's like yeah he was in really bad
yeah it's hurt and they're trying to
conflate that because the lawyers will
keep questioning him about it it's like
yeah i did a bunch of opiates yeah i was
really drunk does that mean i hit her
yeah no right and what what's
embarrassing for her
is that every almost every specific
accusation that she's trying to present
evidence for
either the evidence is fake like oh this
is a picture from an incident in 2013.
turns out look at the metadata it's
2012. wow or you're lying about the
makeup the makeup is not real yeah this
is say that you were the one being you
like everything i think she's live i
think she's an opportunist and of the
worst kind i actually think she's awful
it did that's what it feels like i still
think people like her who are sociopaths
and like this what they do and they're
actually bad people they get found you
can be a really good actor but if you're
on camera long enough
it doesn't matter it will come out you
just you can't hide it no it's just like
what you think is you're saying the
right thing most normal people like oh
no that's not how we talk like good
people don't talk my buddy keith
ferrazzi wrote a book called never eat
alone yeah fake name never eat alone you
might have met him once and he um he
makes he makes his money by taking um
corporations and there are two books
that adam grant wrote a book called give
and take two and the the idea is that
wait i'm sorry that's that guy's two
books or these are two i'm sorry two
separate guys so so adam grant is the
youngest professor in wharton business
school's history okay emmy from borton
it's like a big deal and he did this
study and so did keith they were like
where they looked at people in hollywood
politics and even in business who do
nothing but take and [ __ ] people over
and then he did and then there are
people that actually match so you know
those people go i'll give you something
you give me something back it's called
them they want something back yeah and
then there are people that just give
they just give but they give
strategically to people that are worth
it you can't just give to an idiot you
got to give to people that are worth it
you don't be dumb about it right yeah so
if you like if i ever do somebody a
favor they go thanks i go you're worth
it you are but you also don't expect
anything written no i'm not doing it for
that
you guys are both that just yeah that's
because you can't brag about yourselves
but well
all i want back is friendship right
that's all i want nothing more part of
it's also getting in ten percent growing
up would you eat and ten percent
and and depending who is twenty percent
and maybe twenty two yeah but as you get
older brian it's thirty okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry
now
what the [ __ ] dude my bad how did it go
from my back's
but you're giving you know what you're
right just kidding go ahead
and and what they found though is
through the metadata is that people that
take get found out they get found out
even in politics and they get drum the
[ __ ] out of business because you can't
sustain that for long and it's the same
thing as people who [ __ ] lie to make
a living and then the classrooms the
clintons are listening to this right now
going sure they got that they got found
they're slush we've ran this for a while
sure
sure but
enjoy a slice of uh cosmo pizza on us
oh my god
hillary clinton's listening right now
enjoy
cosmic i was gonna go there i went there
but i was like i went there and talked
to the owner i felt terrible for it of
course
it's just and i told you he was like the
basement oh where we keep children he's
like you know what he was my business
has gone up but dude you know what a
nightmare it's been for me we have death
threats all the time someone shot up the
[ __ ] place here's the basement come
here let me show you the basement here's
come here open that box
yeah but then i did corner my see a
small door where you could go down you
saw a trap door and i heard a kid go hey
you saw little hands yeah that way is
that a pepperoni pizza down there yeah
and that's codeword nothing to see here
that's code word for yeah
small boy yeah they're just making the
boxes yep
the food was delicious i'll go there
again food was fantastic there's a
reason those politicians i'll go there
specifically
well yeah yeah and i was gonna buy merch
from there i'm like that's weird because
i have kids and it's kind of associated
with pets but that bothers me because
they win that the [ __ ] rumor mill
wins yeah but i don't want to be [ __ ]
you know right logo boy rocking cosmic
pizza that sounds like the food the
food's fantastic like those politicians
have all the money in the world there's
a reason they're ordering pizza from
that [ __ ] place you know
yeah most people in politics
um
you you because you don't make any money
as a congressman especially because you
have to have two houses you have to live
in dc and you have to live in your home
state don't feel bad for them they make
all the money no no they don't well what
i'm saying is when you're when you're in
the congress you make at most 160 grand
now now after taxes
after taxes when you have two houses and
live in the most expensive city dc
and you know in your home state it
doesn't go a long way so most people in
congress what people don't realize have
a [ __ ] load of money to begin with they
they oh yeah yeah they're not worried
about that yeah they either come from
family money or they're getting funding
out so with your friendship are they
getting funding from russia china you
know there's weird [ __ ] that goes on man
yup yup
yup but it's beautiful there man in dc
yeah if they didn't have winners i'd be
all over it the capital i realized even
though i went to school there five five
four years i had never been in front of
the capitol really yeah like never stood
there it was like what is wrong with me
dude did you hear the story about
[ __ ] do you ever hear the story boris
yeltsin who was the president of russia
comes to i think with c reagan
and he's um
if you ever you can youtube this he he
was so drunk all the time
in public that he would fall over they
have a guy who would hold him there i
mean he died of drinking he drank all
the all the vodka right why not so he
comes to listen to this he comes to
[ __ ] um always drunk there he is
we'll meet him his same face yes putin
hates that character by the way like
he's like a reaction almost he's like
dude that was disgraceful that yeltsin
was this you know representation of uh
have you ever have you youtubed him
drunk
he's like this
time yeah oh yeah so he goes to that's
my face in 10 years he goes to meet
reagan in dc he's like the president of
russia i mean you're representing i
don't know your country
well
he got so drunk sir
he got so drunk that he
disappeared we just got yeah
when he was they found him
apparently
on the street
right near the white house
and he had no shirt on and just his
pants and we probably just americans but
i thought it was just like some
homelessness that's right you know
having a woman that's right and he was
the
president but maybe he suffers from like
anxiety and stuff he was all nervous to
meet reagan got hammered
no because maybe he's like denzel
washing off training or was it flight
yeah i'm drunk right now now it doesn't
doesn't doesn't hold water because he
was high i'm drunk as [ __ ] all the time
you know it's just never got anything
done yeah but then again johnny depp
like is it is it
safe to say that he spent 30 years
high and drunk
at the top of hollywood's
pyramid high and drunk
yeah but don't make him a bad boy i know
i know i'm just saying it's amazing sure
yeah it's amazing how some people i mean
the guy that plays a [ __ ] pirate for
seven years he's gonna do some drugs
he wears
scarves and mascara such a good actor
though like if you think about all that
he's fantastic dude him is uh [ __ ]
whitey bulger and black mass
what top five
great actor doesn't move use williams
wonka you [ __ ]
you think you're gonna play
you think you're gonna start every tim
burton movie and not two drugs
afterwards how about the guy who played
and yeah tim burton he played the guy
with the what is the guy the mad hatter
or something like that [ __ ]
unbelievable he plays mad hatter he
played willy wonka he played he uh
sleepy hollow incredible dude all those
movies he played some weird [ __ ] as good
as it gets he's gonna do so he wants to
do some drums bring him back
dude do you think you dress up like that
and just normal in your everyday life
click on it when he's in alice in
wonderland look at him which one is it
the bottom right far bottom right
you don't think you're gonna do some
molly every [ __ ] monday friday you
are correct sir you are correct look
alice through the looking glass it's a
good movie i know edward scissorhands
too that was my favorite movie of all
time and he was amazing dude you don't
think you're gonna walk around with
[ __ ] scissors on your hands for
months and not want to do some opiates
you're right what
dude
[Music]
i remember him talking in it i don't
know now that you're thinking no he
talks a ton no not careful i know yeah
careful mister
no he's the main he's the main character
but i don't know he talks but he but he
he's like very shy because he has yeah
yeah scissors for hands so he's insecure
weird you know what hey you know what
you are you're a [ __ ] bully dude
you're bullying edward scissorhands no i
swear like i didn't hear him talk down
he's insecure because he has again
scissors as hands i'm sorry it's my i'm
trying not to be i apologize you can't
help it what else can i say
when i get sick i get my shove around
from the back when i get behind him and
give him a quick shove around maybe but
does that make me that's jyn's favorite
movie of all time it is a great movie my
favorite movie does he speak in it yeah
a lot of time but very like but like
brenda said it's very very shy and like
kind of short yeah but yeah brilliant
it's amazing
the set everything's great look at that
having to walk around with it the music
the music is the best part yeah it's
great and i it was uh danny elfman yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
all of them there you go daddy elfman's
the best dude you don't play these
characters and not do some drugs on
youtube
never come back you gotta open your mind
never come back
ever wow look you just
it's not like he plays normal roles i
gotta watch that movie again oh
fantastic it's on tv every now and then
do you watch it oh yeah watch that oh i
love that movie yeah [ __ ] i've never
actually
probably seen it good movie watch it
brian seriously yeah great well you got
to watch it yeah it still holds up do
you know some of those movies yeah maybe
let's take a little break from chat and
old school style just the boys dudes the
boys cause listen we are some nba heads
here we love us some nba and it's the
west finals the east finals if you're
gonna watch you're paying attention like
my big bro j you're gonna want to watch
you're gonna want to make money because
the nba playoff means next level
basketball the finals east west watch it
make bank with draftkings sportsbook
an official sports betting partner the
nba this week new customers can bet five
dollars on any team to win and get 150
in free bets instantly you win no matter
what
all draftkings sportsbook customers can
also bet on nba hoops with the same game
parlays combine multiple bets from the
same game for your bigger payout the
more legs you add the more money you can
win man plus each day
all right of the finals get a risk-free
bet up to ten dollars if this if your
same game parlay doesn't hit so you're
winning no matter what man download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code fighter bet five dollars on
any nba team to win their game during
the west east final playoff games and
get 150 dollars in free bets instantly
that's promo code fighter at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nba minimum age and
alzheimer's restrictions apply seashell
nose for details see pays for just
direction so for disclaimer see you next
page for disruptions for disclaimer talk
to me about kratom dude you take it
every day chin takes them every day but
then there's a lot of crap on the market
but apparently
super special it's a great
relief that comes from deep within the
rainforest of southeast asia yeah man
farmers have been using kratom alkaloid
rich leaves for hundreds of years for
stamina energy and it reduces pain dude
i use it because it gives me some energy
and i stay lasered focused it's my
limitless pill i love it never feel out
of the zone anymore whether you're doing
work on the computer you're at the gym
you're doing a podcast you're doing
stand-up your boy here has kratom
floating through his veins super
specious kratom better mood equals
better gains man kratom is the healthier
way to unwind we got you man we're
talking about pure kratom leaf only one
freaking ingredient super specio uses
only the top 1 of kratom produced in the
world all right it's 100 satisfaction
guaranteed or your money back all right
all you have to do well you got a super
special kratom and this harvard
exclusively of southeast asia and every
harvest is different once the current
supply sells out it can take months to
be stocked if you have a chance to save
like you do now take advantage if you
want to try it out and if you do go to
super speed show show all right because
they're giving away a massive discount
all you got to do is go to get super
leaf dot com slash fighter use the promo
code fighter for 20 off that's get super
leaf dot com slash fighter promo code
fighter for 20 off get super leaf dot
com slash fighter promo code fighter for
20 off super specio cradle yeah like i
like my kids they drink they eat this
fancy ice cream in calabasas and all
that [ __ ] and whatever after's ice cream
and off to paying it's like the best ice
cream in the world it's like it's like
eight dollars a cone yeah at least they
want double scoops because they're
bastards so i [ __ ] i was like hey you
know when i was your kid
i said
i said when i was your age i had dairy
queen little bastards we're going to
dairy queen forget your afters so i
drove them to dairy queen and i got them
blizzards yeah dude the two and six
they're like what is this garbage like
give me that you know because i don't
need sugar i'm like give me that i was
like oh no it doesn't hold up
it's like watching best of the best when
you were eating regular cream
best of the best deep cold taekwondo
dude yeah i remember you have you seen
best of the best recently i saw best of
us too
it does not hold yeah some movies do big
trouble china holds up all [ __ ] dudes
we were taps with tom cruise taps it was
his first movie
tom cruise taps because we're younger
yeah yeah but but it was from 1981 i
wanted to see if that was it i wasn't
born yet so i'll tell you right now
doesn't hold up you know his you know
his his new movie uh
the new top gun yeah they waited for
people to give uh look at him
jesus christ it was awesome so on that
top gun they waited they said hey you
can write reviews but do it on this day
whatever reviews you have just wait but
so it doesn't paint the narrative
before this comes out just wait then
they allowed and release it on this day
it's like a 99 on rotten tomatoes if
they're saying it's like the best movie
they've seen in what years like i've
been so all over dude
the the reviews of that they're like
what hands down the best movie we've
seen in theaters in years what are you
talking about yeah it's supposed to be
unfucking
they've been holding it until the
pandemic's over it's been done forever
my boy miles teller is in it he's one of
the main stars and he they shot it years
ago they've been waiting and val kilmer
is in it again what yeah
oh i'm all over this [ __ ]
apparently the movie's supposed to be
unreal and i'm i'm not big i saw a
poster
jennifer connelly yeah i'm not a huge
top gun guy oh my lord
but after you read the reviews you're
like well maybe i should see it
poor val kilmer he had that yeah a
throat cancer yeah poor guy um
yeah yeah but apparently the movie's
supposed to be like the best in years
it's supposed to crush it hasn't even
gone like nationwide yet either
damn this did like a private screening
in hollywood and everyone came out was
like best movie i've ever seen i'm going
to buy a flight jacket i'm going to
watch that [ __ ]
i was never in there i was never that
into it i was never that into it
i wasn't either and you know what and
also the volleyball scene i was like man
this is gay yeah well i watched i
remember now i watched in 85. you saw it
in the theaters
yeah like 1985.99 so i was in the 80s
being as literal as possible so when you
saw a dude with uh oil on his body
shaved down you didn't nobody in the
theater was like those guys shaved down
those guys took steroids or those guys
have oil in their bodies
that guy's awesome and also he's wearing
a t-shirt uh an undershirt he's wearing
he's tucked in a tank top yeah and and
he's wearing his pants super high and
they're pleated but that's awesome we
didn't think that when when stallone is
tying
the bandana around his head we're like
he probably needs that because it makes
sense we weren't making
we weren't making fun of that that was
new for us so we were literal we were
like that's cool well it's 20 22 and now
we you get a little bit of that stuff
now we're back to it well maybe not
really the volleyball scene dude
what are the classic homoerotic moments
in cinema history really ever can you
watch that no absolutely
hey i'll do my face i know this for 20
years
there he is hold on dude hold on first
he has jeans on dude bro
these guys are cut shredded yeah
that's spiking and going yeah that's not
him that's the other guy the
over-the-top handshake the pump yeah
there you go oh here we go there look at
that and you got by the way i love
anthony edwards he's i'll keep my shirt
on [ __ ] this oh that's him now
yeah he uh
he was in a couple of movies
yeah grabbing each other like that okay
dude if you grab me like that on the be
i'm like
[ __ ] what are you doing dude you spiked
it so hard i'm like i don't care yeah
why are you grabbing me like we're
[ __ ] later guys being dudes
yeah
we're gonna have sex later
guys let's take a sex break
also who's that end of time tap time
also who's into that volleyball aren't
you guys fighter
this is you're getting your rocks off on
beach you will feel like a non-athlete
in that [ __ ] and that's sam trying to
jump i get an inch off the ground i do
want to see it now though
once i read the reviews i'm like oh [ __ ]
everybody but when i saw it i have to i
remember it was an awesome movie but i i
remember
feeling a little bit embarrassed only
because it was so
it was so uh you know a little it's a
great movie but like you know flying jet
i knew what it was i knew what it was
doing to me i you know sometimes you're
watching movies you know you [ __ ] up
right because before you're saying you
did it
what you're saying you did it like the
homoerotic like the the gene shorts
playing ball no i'm saying i'm saying
though you're saying like i saw top gun
and i it was a great movie but i didn't
want to be a fighter pilot because i was
like you guys are pulling a trick on me
that's how i'm supposed to feel so oh
gotcha that's all
but i remember being there i remember me
and my buddy and there was a guy and he
and he went there with a fighter
pilot jacket on oh hell yeah and he was
standing there answering questions and
me and my buddy looked at me go that
guy's never flown a plane in his [ __ ]
life no fighter pilots aren't coming to
the movie theaters to answer questions
somebody walks by and goes that guy
doesn't fly
i was like
that's all he has a guy flies for spirit
airlines ladies and gentlemen oh my god
yep i want to see it now though
as do i
i'm telling you look at those reviews
it's nutsos i want to see that i can't
wait what do you know what that premise
is
uh it's a group of young fighter pilots
and they need like someone to train them
because they have to go on this big
mission and they're like you know how
movies are like somebody call what's the
what's that somebody call me maverick
doll
do we have to he's like i don't want to
but he is the man for the job and then
he tom cruise walks in he's like i don't
be as much as anybody else doesn't want
to be here but i have to do it and then
the country he's teaching the young
bucks the tricks of the trade your
country that's awesome we need this yeah
yeah dude we got to get maverick that
those are still some of my favorite
movies where it's like the [ __ ] do we do
i like that get the cobra yeah i like
that call the cobra call the cobra well
i like uh like they'll do uh previews
for avatar too
hey man
i saw avatar in
two the year 2000 it's
21 years ago you're coming out with part
two now that's like cars 15 years later
or uh the incredibles 15 i guess i
remember the first one yeah avatar is an
amazing movie
and part two took i thought avatar was
an amazing movie no
hold on it's foreign i thought avatar
personally okay was one of the best
movies i'd seen i i really i still feel
that way i got lost in it because i
watched it in 3d did you get everybody i
knew have you heard about this avatar of
depression people commit suicide because
they wanted that world to be so real
that means it's a powerful movie
people are crazy right that too because
i went through it back to reality yes
but i'm not a blue giant great movie
though right phenomenal okay but a lot
of people i know were like ah [ __ ]
screenplay boo i was like what talking
about what are you talking about those
are so good the only criticism is it's
the exact same plot as fern golly i
don't know fern gully it's a cartoon
robin williams played batty in it i
don't care about that though but it's
the exact same plot that came out in the
night i was lost in it i got lost and i
loved it i loved avatar yeah and i did i
wanted to be in that world i wanted to
be oh i didn't you know why it's not
real right is it not real or is is it
not are we headed that way you think
is this an avatar are we in
like
a situation talk to some mathematicians
no but i don't talk to them right
well because you're afraid that we might
be in a simulation
no i've told you this before only broke
people think we're gonna like only super
rich people think we're in a simulation
go ask the guy making your fries the
mcdonald's a furnace no but i mean
mathematics he's like computer
scientists elon musk they all talk about
it yeah i mean you almost the rich guy
in the world like i'm too rich this has
to be a simulation it's like all right
dude yeah i guess man no but the idea
it's not a way to live but they're
they're no but they're their
mathematicians are they it's the idea is
what's beyond evolution biology like
what's the next thing so the so
evolution was this huge scientific
discovery what's the next step it could
be that evolution is happening within a
larger context which is a simulation
mathematically
and i'd say show me proof well and then
you go well we can't okay yeah enjoy
your coffee that's my time we might be
we are we might smart machines made by
our biological heritage that's all so
you just yeah i don't know what you do
with that though let's say it's true
what do we do well what would you do
it's not you do anything but you have a
deeper understanding of the the cycle
that's going on it just kind of changes
but then if you go down that road then
get into religion
right if you want to believe that stuff
longer conversation
similar though if you have faith in
conversation if you're gonna have faith
in we're in a simulation you're having
faith you're putting your faith into
something yeah so that if there's a
bigger meaning yes well so think about
it so facts if you're just going to go
on facts right
facts are unending this is
a never-ending
there's a never-ending kind of
supply of facts
i can come up with a thousand different
kind of facts about anything no you
can't come up with facts that prove that
no that's what i'm saying god or that's
what i'm saying simulation that's why
those facts don't that's why the notion
exactly that's why the notion of god the
paradigm this the structure that give of
belief and faith is sort of the is sort
of the attempt to say yeah there are a
lot of facts but let's
this is the truth this is let's start
with this truth this story this this
story is the truth that that would be
the idea it's a longer i don't want to
get it dicey yeah it's a long
conversation but no please break it down
just kidding i'm just kidding it's
fascinating
jane you got to concert this uh [ __ ]
tomorrow dude you got a concert are you
nervous you look nervous i'll be front
[ __ ] row yes we do harley's
performing too
hell mark harley chin we have like
eminem
is that i heard it mgk with full makeup
katy perry's opening for you guys which
is rumors
but we have a guy named bobby raps riley
there's more like art phenomenally yeah
they're so talented yeah super lexi yeah
yeah do you know who i'm a secret fan of
who and i've still not admitted it but
i'm like i'm
the way i guess a 14 year old girl would
be yeah please who do i like do you
think uh billy eilish it's a girl i love
her actually she's really good but no
i'm i'm a huge fan of miley cyrus i
think she's no she's actually like a
good singer she's a legitimately good
singer and when she does uh
covers yeah pink floyd [ __ ] i'm like no
she's stupid talking jolie yeah
have you gotten sexy to me except yeah
she's not there at this concert chin
have you gone uh hey man don't don't
don't brush over my love for miley i
know but i thought it was gonna be
someone like kind of like not that
everybody loves you know what i'm saying
is there all adults in 55 listening
so big but guys my age my dad digs her
really yeah yeah he likes her music yeah
her cup to your point her covers i don't
think yeah well wrecking ball was
good good too i heard the i heard her
sing that
on stern with the acoustic version she's
so good
which seems like joe lee
is really good yeah so this is you guys
for the yeah by the way but covers i did
a cover of uh remember faith evans she
was with uh
yes b.i.g
yeah yeah notorious i did a cover of
that and one of the my
right now my favorite artist for now is
called ernest he's the one that's
throwing with morgan wallin yeah i did a
cover now he started following me and he
actually commented on my cover no the
most beautiful stuff and it just made my
entire like jacket you're talented i
didn't jack off but i was like but you
were rocking super hard you finally got
the boner why not you yeah why not you
chin and by the way i performed the
troubadour it's [ __ ] awesome it's
downtown right no no no no it's uh west
hollywood oh okay that's not too bad
it's not too bad it's on uh now here's
where it gets nice it's on fairfax
you're not going up right
here here's where it gets
my papa i didn't know this he's been in
santa barbara he goes hey we can only
come we leave wednesday morning so we're
coming to stay with you tuesday night
all right so i'm gonna make you dinner
and then you know well i'll see the kids
we're only there tuesday night i said
when my friend has a concert he goes
don't give a [ __ ] fair point you're live
i swear on my life yeah swear in my life
yeah my dad's coming tomorrow night yeah
not that my dad's not coming to the
concert yeah grills every time he comes
he grills on a tuesday huh yeah i swear
swear to god
i'll show you the text you can hey you
can calm down i would love to go you're
going to show me i still can't ask your
mom as well you're going to show me your
text my mom you're going to be like i'll
show you the text well they're divorced
yeah no i know you [ __ ] up right no i
know but that's how you like that i even
asked my mom i swear yeah but you're i i
think i might be able to make it if my
dad can do dinner like six is you won't
go on to like nine ish uh 9 45 or okay
well too late yeah right
yeah
if you can show up that's awesome you
don't have to you've supported me hey
and us so much already so you don't have
a shot you're getting it
brian i'm also like thinking if you're
gonna show up i don't have any oh no
here's the difference for me and brian
i'll be honest it's gonna be very tough
because my dad's coming time brian will
s flank brian will say he's gonna go
absolutely will not show that's my first
concert and i'm going right to the
captain troubadour
i kind of meal i do believe brian will
be there i'll be there okay well we'll
see though where is it
wait where is that again
the troubadour los angeles
who kicks off the concert chappelle in
his band called uh mad piece and that's
gonna be you hard rock how long are you
not gonna be that's not hard that's
that's uh that's uh
noise that's very directed
yeah is that fair it's called it's
called yelling therapy
hardcore punk rock okay that's something
gonna miss that very good they're really
good yeah sure if you like that genre
pop he's great pop is gonna miss that
because that gives me anxiety so then
who's after chappelle and the death
metal i think me and brows go on okay so
brows goes on first and he'll introduce
me and we'll do a few but if uh
chappelle and them start at eight
they're not going for an hour and 40. so
the doors open at eight but chappelle
probably goes on at nine with his band
oh man you're not hitting the stage too
i guess i've been doing a long time
you're not in the stage until 11
probably right there's like no so for
for me and brows will be on by like 9
45-ish i'll be on after like four or
five songs
and i'll do my own stuff for like the
only reason i'm going is to see you chin
now the problem is what time are you
going home because right now it sounds
like right i'll be on around
9 45 45 no you won't be you'll be on i
bet they promise you i bet you they will
but doors are at eight we're
professionals though we we we're super
professional every time we do shows
we're coming i said i was coming i'm
coming i don't want to come back can you
stream that live
i don't know i'll be there i'll be there
i'll be there um
cameras and [ __ ]
yeah i can't wash it in my from my
living room no it's gonna be fun though
it'll be fun yeah
i know i'm like
this is your second time doing a larger
kind of thing like this we've done a few
shows together me and brows
and then he's a talent yeah he's super
talented and there's so many talented
people that are coming that are guest uh
you know artists so it's gonna be a
great show
how about jelly roll has the number one
rock problem in the world what wow i
love jell-o no
his country song hit number one for sure
on a radio station wow he's not killing
the guy at the gym who does music mark
was like yeah your boy jelly roll has
the number one rock wow in the country
you know
that's so impressive isn't that cool
yeah wow
your arms are impressive
i'm very happy with your hands and
wrists oh you like that let's talk about
steroids
please don't do that and your thick
hands that's not steroids that
the wrists and hands are uh your bone
structure yeah and i mean it is funny
one of the things you learn early on
with women they'll be like i was into
this guy but then his hands were tiny
yes i'm like oh that's a thing yeah you
don't want real tiny hands yeah there's
a i read a book about that this woman
was like she's a tiny hand this guy
there's a full book on tiny hands called
the autobiography donald trump listen
and she said i never forgot this she was
like i can't stand them he was she was
[ __ ] this dude who was like this guy
you know this kind of rogue you know but
she was married to this guy who paid all
her bills and i remember she was like i
can't just in her mind as he's eating
she couldn't stand him because he was
buttering his toast
just so and he had pointy little fingers
she was like look at his little hands
it's so petty but we can picture it
i'd be pissed off too
tiny hands like but specifically the
pointiness of it when you know when a
man's hands like kind of come to a
little point and they're just like it's
like that
guy who's never done manual labor at his
life now he has no idea he has no
calluses yeah that's tough
so well i'm looking forward to your
concert jen thanks brandon if you show
up that'll be
incredible you don't you don't have to
you've done so much you're not going to
yourself but i'm going to no this is a
chance yeah it makes it and i'm going to
hand out because my papa goes better
only 10 shots my papa goes out early too
that's incredible dude
uh i don't know if this is like a pr
well i'll just play this real quick
why is browsing what's up guys happening
tuesday the 17th at the troubadour okay
we got mad peaceful we got little brows
chin yeah it's going down that's our
first show first show together in l.a
it's a diverse show you got hardcore and
country country all your [ __ ]
top 40 hits
i'm seeing us out there excited to play
for you guys we're gonna put on a good
show for you good sound girl
what's that what's up guys it's happy
it's good though the energy's off the
charts
we suck at this we're brand new dude we
don't know what the hell we're just
kidding yeah we saw no but the lighting
was good
i had my tripod on the street yeah and
then some a sheriff pulled up right and
i'm like [ __ ] we're gonna get uh this
because you know you got permits to film
right oh so then i'm like oh crap i
brought the camera over here and then
the guy pulled up backed up and he goes
no no it's all good i'm fans of the
shows you guys do
a sheriff guy
yeah his name is abel he didn't want to
he don't want to say his name but his
name is abel
super cool guy yeah that's awesome
yeah he just outed that man yeah there's
so many you're a goody two shoes huh
there's so many
because pulled up and i had my little
tripod i was like hey bro be cool it's
gonna take ten seconds man be [ __ ]
you know when you're paying taxes he's
like whoa easy dude exactly
yeah but he was cool he was awesome so
but thank you guys for letting me do
this that's cool you're worth it buddy
it's all you buddy appreciate what we
say all you man as long as i get to get
up on stage and do some [ __ ] with you oh
my god if you did that would be
incredible i'll just dance yeah and
dance on there take your
pop gun style
all right so that'd be fun why did you
hesitate i think it'd be fun take your
shirt
you turn it off i was gonna say pants
but yeah we don't need you know it's not
you know
yeah
yeah all right what do you got all right
all right i'm sure you know that you
know what that's more than i do brandon
yeah tom brady so after he's done with
his football career fox hired him to do
a 10-year contract for 375.7 375 million
dollars to do you know whatever oh my
god hosting if i'm if i'm tom brady
though
it's you know his wife makes more money
than him they have all the money so it's
like he's already had you're going to
retire and then your point of retiring
was like spend more time in the family
do all that stuff but then doing this
stuff you're on the i didn't grow just
for the same amount you do all the
studying yeah you think about that dude
it's a beast to be like a top analyst
you gotta go notes in the prep and
you're on the road all the time like
he's a beast man [ __ ] yeah so he did a
lot of work i thought he could do it
just from one
hub but i guess not they could be at the
game
yeah so she has they're paying him that
money he's going to be the face of fox
you know all these promos all that [ __ ]
man
i don't get it if you have that money i
guess you want to stay busy but still i
think his personality has to stay busy i
don't i don't know
how you go from being that intense well
drew brees walked away from uh he was
doing uh i think thursday night football
he walked away from cbs i think he did
one year with them and walked away
i think he's coming back no they think
he's coming back to football
really the rumor is coming back to the
saints who knows but
again i think all those guys they're
like yeah i'm down to do it but then
it's like all right well here's the prep
here's the work down the road still like
we're paying you millions of dollars
it's a lot yeah it's interesting right
yeah but i'm tom brady like i'll figure
something else out man i don't want to
do this yeah i don't know
10 years
my
375
is like you're right like you get close
to that stuff and you realize this is a
lot of work and not what i thought it
was necessarily it's a very specific
skill i don't know be interesting no he
can do it he's going to dominate and
like tony roma is one of the best but
yeah it just takes it's a lot of work
yeah you're still like so involved in
the game
yeah i know all the teams all the
players
coaches
yeah at that point like what do you it
was between him and his wife he'll be
damned near a billionaire like they're
so rich
it's like why do it man something to do
i guess yeah something to do
it's cool
yeah
all right he shot at my um
sister's house
what do you mean um he and morgan
freeman they used my sister's house oh
yeah and uh he was and they didn't want
to bother him but he saw my sister's dog
she's got that huge bull mastiff yeah
he's covered and started talking he was
[ __ ] apparently just great oh [ __ ]
yeah this is this sucks but uh so this
is in dallas texas
a coyote
literally went after a two-year-old kid
dragged him out they were able to get
the kid but apparently the kid was in
critical condition jesus christ but now
he's stable
and this is kind of rare this is super
rare no this isn't that rare because a
cody coyote just attacked another
person on the beach right in california
i don't know about the beach but this is
kind of a rare thing it doesn't happen
often and people sometimes say that the
coyotes might have rabies and that's why
they're attacking kids
i don't know
well but they'll go after like your dogs
and cats for sure
actual human beings you know what i'm
talking about pictures in california on
the beach maybe it can't be florida
there's no [ __ ] coyotes in florida
pretty sure it's california yeah they're
there in florida there yep yep there
everywhere do that for one show rogan
had a guy on um the hunted beach there
you go hunting beasts
developing tonight a little girl's
recovering at the hospital after she was
attacked and bitten by a coyote on
huntington beach huntington beach dude
look try getting her does it happen
do these people not have no clue they
don't you don't hear it
oh come on you don't hear about it
oh jesus that is terrible
well now coyote is attacking that's so
crazy
it's your food to it and they're not
that small with them in my backyard all
the time not small no they're not but
they're usually afraid like it i've been
around coyotes before too if you
even like walk up to them they just run
away they're not the ones in my neck
rogan had a guy on about coyotes and
they're the most adaptive animals yeah
maybe the yes they're the most adaptable
animal literally on the planet and they
will eat fruit if they don't anything
else just to survive yeah they can they
and they they usually they don't need a
pack they'll pair up together they can
be alone they can just do anything they
eat your cats they'll eat everything you
know what the canadian coyotes are huge
i guess because like some woman was
eaten by one like and somebody heard her
screaming in the distance on this trail
and caught up in his like but like you
think a coyote couldn't take me down but
apparently they're giant in canada more
like like wolves they're huge up there
dude the ones in the valley man they're
no punk there's like three or four of
them you just see them all the time yeah
like
don't not giving a [ __ ] about cars
people they're just doing their thing
was that little girl okay on hunting the
beach i didn't see the
she didn't die
yeah she didn't die and luckily that kid
was he was in critical in the beginning
but now he's stable so that's good it
was like lacerations on the face i
always have some [ __ ] balls yeah we
haven't heard about this for a while
though so it's so
people should know is that when a dog or
a coyote sometimes attacks a child
you expect the kid to scream and you
expect the dog to be making noise that's
not what happens
a lot of times when dogs go into that
predatory mode or they attack a child
they're very quiet and they bite like a
big cat a pit bull got my my son when he
was on a swing and got on top of him and
started like basically
got him off the swing and and there was
no noise dude and i grabbed that dog and
pulled that dog off but he didn't bite
no he didn't bite he was she it was a
female she was um
what was it looked like she was about to
my son was probably [ __ ] three but i
never forgot i was like that could have
happened and i that dog could have been
biting my kid and i never seen and what
the dog was not being friendly is on the
plate yes the dog the dog attacked my
kid knocked him off the swing and was on
top of him and was you could hear about
his mouth he's going like this
like that he's kind of going no i think
what the dog was doing is keeping the
kid down like saying uh you know like
like that dominance thing yeah but dude
i've been around i've had pimples my
whole life you it takes that quick and
they're they're they're on and also if
they're going for the neck it's like try
screaming with something clamping on
your vocals yeah
that is just scary
didn't rogan ever tell that story about
how uh he was at the vet and they they
this or the vet was his vet said
they bring a pit bull and and it needed
uh literally something like
oh you told this story
with the coyotes and they they followed
the thermal blood trail up they found
nine dead male coyotes love that
this pit bull was like oh you guys want
to [ __ ] with me i don't feel pain
he got [ __ ] up though he got [ __ ] up
but he was actually fine
no rogan said the next day the bed said
he was popping his stitches because he
was playing jesus christ
so
scary crazy
so yeah watch your kids
dude i look i pop my face pops with this
awesome do you guys hear about this i
imagine you guys have yeah he did it
from his house yes from his apartment so
it's it's called it's not that special
wow with nora macdonald or nothing
special
i guess his sister-in-law is the one
that uh um announced this but yeah so he
recorded something in his apartment
during the pandemic so yeah he didn't
really pandemic and he knew he had
cancer but he didn't tell anybody
well you and i were hanging out with him
at the store he's asking about betting i
don't know he's a degenerate gambler
huge he kept asking about fight picks
i'm like what is happening yeah probably
goes shop
draftkings but i remember that i
remember and he was so great go shop
dude
but what do you know what kind of cancer
so concerned yeah we're gonna find out
what kind of case i'll look it up right
now but so it's gonna be released may
30th on netflix now you said about
netflix they were they made some changes
yeah i did a statement basically saying
you know they've been so woke lately but
they're losing subscriptions because you
can't have a business model like that
end of the day
i don't think
you know it's about money so their thing
was is um
cu cancer center um but their thing was
hey we're done pushing this agenda of
this woke [ __ ]
if any employee at netflix has an issue
it's up to the artist we're not going to
dictate and suppress whatever voice they
want to have freedom of expression and
then they go if you have a problem you
can quit and leave yeah get out of it
and elon musk uh post it and re uh tweet
it with a quote says uh smart basically
this is like this of course yeah let the
artist let yeah because even disney's
down like a half a billion dollars their
stock since they've been doing all this
woke [ __ ] yeah extra stuff it's
interesting getting involved in politics
yeah but norma mcdonald's gonna be sick
what else you got jen
all right let's see here
um
actually you know what not that much
more mark should we do this one
it's just more funny than anything okay
so i'll pull this out i want this one i
can see it
no no not this one oh a different one
okay i'll pull it over now it's on world
star your favorite thing
uh just play yeah
keep coloring here
ready
set
go
oh oh my god i was gonna say this what
happens when you don't understand
physics oh boy that is another guy's
300 pounds he didn't mean it but god
damn it that's so awful is that kid okay
yeah all these pages they record it and
they play it on yeah kids okay usually
there'll be a scripture like kids okay
it's okay yeah that's damn that was so
intense [ __ ] come on dad
oh you know you're playing with your
kids you know what yeah like that when
last time we're in montana they have
these frisbee i don't know what are
these frisbees there dude they might
wait no i'm not even trying to be funny
10 pounds like they're thick like thick
rubber wait what what are you saying
frisbees yeah and so my son we were
playing frisbee and i go go deep and he
was so far it's this huge green line i
go go deep and as hard as i could you
know there's i'm like
and he goes to catch it and it was too
hard he goes through his hands and goes
i was like oh well i'm the worst dad on
earth and i go i'm gonna buy rounds for
everybody i didn't i didn't mean to do
that you dude you felt like in your head
you're like yeah he's gonna catch
because he's never not caught it yeah
and then that thick frisbee
my son i was teaching him how to kick
and we have this like you know that with
the weighted heavy bag yeah and it's
like this it's a kid's thing and he's
holding and i go hold on okay so i'm
going to show you i ca i just showed him
i think i like sidekicked or something
back kick and it it it
it went in but this part went
like super hard
yeah man [ __ ] really hurt him right
in the eye
down like knocked him i was i felt like
a [ __ ] oh god sometimes
my dad uh at my grandpa's house he
passed away but we're at his house
because after he passed away my dad was
like going through his stuff because he
wanted to keep some stuff he's a war
veteran so we're going through i was
like six we're going through his uh
garage and he finds pepper spray my dad
goes i think this thing still works and
he goes to spray it but there's a wind i
don't know what my dad was thinking he
was the thing there's so he sprays the
pepper spray it goes
the wind goes not today your problem
right my eyes my eyes going it's going
my daughter did that i freaked the [ __ ]
out i bought my my ex uh pepper spray
and she had it there my daughter was at
the stables and she was
five and she thought it was lipstick or
something
and she [ __ ] got in her eyes my
daughter almost she went into shock yeah
i didn't feel so good what's up about
the guy how about the guy here ice
fishing you hear about the story they're
ice fishing and the guy has a stick of
dynamite when you take the stick of
dynamite you light it and you throw it i
guess to blow a hole in the [ __ ] ice
and then go over and like do your set up
shop yeah yeah
what happened
what happened dropped it
throws it what he forgot is that his dog
loves to play badge
yeah and his dog goes yeah he's like no
and the dog just goes
yeah kills his daughter that's sad no i
haven't heard that story yeah that's a
terrible story it looks like that we had
a wasp hive at my house in aurora and my
dad goes here this is a wasp repellent
so just stay there and spray it
well
dad i was like again seven or eight this
is after the pepper spray in the eyes he
gives me he goes don't worry i'll make
it up to you here's a bottle of wasp
spray just stand from the hive and spray
them they're gonna kill oh they fly out
like great idea he was right i'm gonna
go to the garage and get other stuff you
stay here and spray them like such a
good idea father this isn't right dude
i'm spraying wasps don't go [ __ ] ape
[ __ ] on you or anything bro
i'm all shh and it's [ __ ]
they come out like it's like we're
storming normally oh no you're no
they're gonna kill you oh excuse me sir
i i'm not trying to make you laugh i get
stung in the eye and then the neck
dude and you're lucky you got away with
just that the eye and neck the worst
thing in the world and the only thing
worse is getting stung in your dick and
my dad goes i thought i told you
hey now as a grown man what were you
thinking papa
of course you're not gonna hit all of
them
the guy blew his [ __ ] face off with a
shotgun when he had they saw the
rattlesnake and he and he takes the butt
of the gun and holds the rattle snake
down and on his head and he's like ah
yeah and the rattlesnake what they do
with their bodies they go like that and
got that trigger and went chip up
and boom rattlesnake said not today
because the end
[Music]
holy [ __ ] there are all kinds of
problems
it's just not the way to go yeah
oh
what's this now i'm going to because
argue with the drive-through guy who's
just trying to do his job and work for
now i will give him this when you order
a postmates and like that sauce makes
the meal and they forget the sauce yeah
you want to die yeah
die that and shuttle shuttles to the
rental car i told when you text me that
you're playing the dc loft you take a
shuttle from the airport
nothing makes you feel more like a loser
than a shuttle on this planet well when
you're sitting there with your luggage
and i want to say this i like i miss my
flight because i'm an [ __ ] and
there's no other reason you sleep
no they just change the gate and i have
to push it miss my flight you like to
push it walk seven terminals over and
buy a flight on united and it's in 31f
and then and i'm not trying to be i had
i i was in the window seat wedged and
the two guys who sat next to me were the
big they were you sent me a picture yeah
yeah the biggest people in the world
they were the biggest people in the
world they were let's
call names but you sat next to honey boo
boo's mom yes very big people
and and i and i thought and the guy was
essentially in pajamas and and i had a
judgment on him i i judged a book by its
cover
and then i realized he was like one
thing i noticed he was sitting next to
me he was so [ __ ] nice he was so kind
to the guy next to him who started
talking about his weight they're both
yeah and they they were talking about
about their struggles yeah but he was so
kind wow
how nice is that to be open about your
weight struggles and the guy next year's
like me too it was actually and so now
but but more importantly
i then hear him on the phone he's kind
of giving orders and like he's he's
running something
turns out he runs a number of
dispensaries
and
he was so
[ __ ] intelligent
so smart he runs a bunch of these
different things he had such insight on
business like were you judging because
he was fat i just had a judgment on
pajamas we all judge people on
appearance sometimes there was just a
look that i thought was
you know and uh i felt like the biggest
[ __ ] because i was like i had a
wonderful conversation did you apologize
soon [ __ ] no i didn't say anything did
you go hey sir
you're fat don't judge a book by its
cover it wasn't that it was i never did
i never i never assumed he was a guy
with a beard this big with his hair
everything was just like he literally
said this he said to his head he goes
i'm going to let you grow for one year
like some people will go show up and
they look like um they've been a
castaway yeah it was more that and then
the clothes were just it was it was
incredible
smart now did he get out seven rv cues
on the plane or just makes the plane say
he didn't do a goddamn thing i was
making him laugh we were having a laugh
and he was just a
what got me was how kind he was to the
guy who was even bigger next to him he
was so kind to casino like that you know
he's such a beast he's so such a beast
yeah you're an [ __ ] been blowing me
away with his [ __ ] big brain so yeah
don't judge a book by its cover and
don't especially when you fight a guy
right if you're going to fight some dude
on the street what do you thought about
fighting him no
i was thinking about it i was watching
this documentary on julio
cesar chavez you look him with a shirt
off he looks like a a guy who was julia
chavez yes
he was a b you shouldn't have tried a
book no
not really
senior senior oh my
he also has the biggest live gate of all
time yeah and what
not that's right go to images not that
not not a guy you'd expect to be one of
the greatest boxers of all time
oh that's what you're saying images you
get your ass [ __ ] kicked of course
but i'm just saying
don't judge a book by its cover
everybody
yeah who's the most who's the white guy
who's the one guy in in yeah who's the
one guy in mma do you think he's the
most unassuming but the baddest guy
kenny florian yeah
yeah he was or his his boy is protege
the other jiu-jitsu monster oh ryan hall
[Applause]
yeah he'll just take your [ __ ] ankle
well dude oh you want that [ __ ] to ryan
hall in a bar dude he's going to get you
an ankle lock and then you're having to
have surgery on your ligaments and
you're in rehab like it's a six-month
mistake that's correct you have to get
rehab and all that that's if you're a
high level fighter but he can do
anything he wants to can he tell me he
rolled with ryan hall and he goes i've
been doing this my whole life i roll
with that guy it's like it's like uh i'm
trying to grab water it's getting tapped
[ __ ] left and right but i don't know
anybody yeah what's going on with our
boy kane
they denied him [ __ ] bail today
they said he's a liability yeah yeah
he tried to appeal the first one today
we thought he was gonna get bail they
denied him bail
reckless disregard for human life
the the judge is a complete [ __ ]
complete [ __ ] that's why you gotta
hope he goes to a jury and the jury you
know sides with cain you can understand
that that one moment of red but in his
however he's 38 yeah 37 years
you take 37 years and 364 days he's been
a model citizen that means nothing to
you
and then you want to put him away for
what i guess he's looking at 20 years
well then you're going to ruin his
household so the kids that grow up
without a father so this is nothing only
about mr gullart [ __ ] that guy and his
family but this court is considering
every single citizen in santa clara
county who is in proximity to this
alleged incident oh really okay thanks a
lot here's what [ __ ] kane is the the dad
that he shot i guess he hit an artery
and the dad can't work and then like
some of his fingers he said he can't use
they don't work anymore so he shot the
dad as well accidentally because he
wanted he's trying to drop the shoot the
predator
molested his child yeah trouble did this
guy so is this guy mr goal art he is
guilty of this [ __ ] not yet yeah
but according to kane he is
i'm gonna side with cain on this yeah
listen to your kids
yeah you need a jury because the
clearless judge looks at kane like a
human cop fighter does not look at him
like a professional athlete that's right
and all the dude 300 i mean [ __ ] 37
years of model citizen the face of the
ufc a great mexican-american great work
ethic good person gives back community
one error right big air a lot a lot a
lot of felonies a lot of felonies
in california uh that that that one
incident
hitting people uh ramming people off the
road seven miles it's it's uh it's uh
yeah i'm not condoning i'm just saying
like well you're yeah you're going to
pay a price for that regardless in
california he's going to go away but it
shouldn't be 20 years man and you're
ruining another how many people's lives
you want to be ruined
i agree it's not good well everybody
everybody sympathizes with a man who's
child that's right a jury will
definitely sympathize with him that's
what we need
what do you got jim
all right so
[Music]
our bully mark has been sending me some
cool stuff
especially from uh world star so here's
one of them
i think we already did this one let's do
this
oh she left her car running
oh wow oh we're crossing
how yeah she got out of the car to argue
with the uh drive-through workers pride
about the sauce man yeah i'll come back
y'all come back now
y'all come yeah i don't think she heard
that yeah well that's really scary too
your car's just away car and hit
somebody my god man oh yeah oh god and
this one mark yeah he was wearing a
gopro where he got knocked out
what are you why are you going at them
like that
this is historic because it's labeled as
the first gopro knockout ever it's from
your point of view you just witnessed
history
[Laughter]
i guess this might be the last one then
yeah all right it's an unbelievable mark
what is this
yes they're alive i didn't hear that
audio that probably would have made me
think it
[ __ ] way but female drivers huh
yeah you don't want to be uh he's down
dude the gopro's not moving
are you okay no i'm not okay
[Music]
that is funny that she said are you okay
as [ __ ] no i'm not okay maybe you could
skip that please okay they say if you're
talking you're breathing son yeah oh
there's some world starcraft right there
broken legs
he said no i'm not okay are you out of
your mind he did he did a revolution
yeah yeah
yeah revolution will
i don't get on motorcycles because i
expect that i know yeah but yeah like
what the crazy thing is how that doesn't
happen all the time every day 24 7.
motorcycles look fun but there's
everyone i know who's been on the
motorcycle it's not a matter of if it's
when 100 yeah well even when you go to
take the lessons which i did they said
there's 99 chance you're going to record
the first year 99
and they go it could just be a little
thing or a big thing but 99 percent
change
what no i don't want those was like yeah
don't buy a nice motorcycle for your
first one
i've had enough i was in mexico and
tried to rent one of those mopeds being
like i got this never read one before
and like the first thing i do is like
tip
right in front of the guy's like hey no
come here come here a lot of people they
rent those mopeds in like costa rica
yeah
they do it on islands like in mykonos
that's all they do the doctor goes i i
just for me i can save you the trouble
if you've never ridden a moped and you
want to get on that i can save you
trouble i can just take a baseball bat
and a sander to your knees or your legs
if you want i mean or you you can do it
that way
well i rented a moped to get around
philadelphia this thursday friday
saturday and be on moped around
brotherly love city philadelphia and i
will be at suplex at noon buying
sneakers and we got a special collab
merch uh thick boy and suplex can only
get it in person at suplex that saturday
at noon i will be there with the squad
buying kicks come on out they're gonna
have food they're doing a big event for
that uh but thursday friday saturday
that's this week may 19th through 21st
i'm in philly at the helium then next
week next wednesday one show only uh
shop and friends the hollywood improv is
may 25th that's wednesday at 8 p.m it's
being some monsters a very special guest
then portland oregon the trash panda
tour continues portland oregon june 9th
through the 11th san francisco cobb is
june 17th through the 18th and san diego
at a new club there the laugh factory
san diego i opened for chris there it's
one of my favorite clubs now in san
diego it's heart of san diego downtown
san diego
lab factory san diego's july 21st
through the 23rd but philly you're up
this freaking week and the special we're
about to hit a million baby we're at
8.70
right now we're about to clear a mill
okay let's do it kids the whole staff
gets taken to scopa yeah yeah watch it
uh why uh uh washington thank you dc
loft brea improv i am sold out the first
show still some tickets left for the
second show barely i'm so excited i
shoot that on thursday get your tickets
may 19th i wish i could go no thursday
[ __ ] up you're the first special
you've not been to i know you know i
know uh then west palm beach florida one
of my favorite places on the planet the
improv may 27 28 29 that's a friday
saturday
sunday yeah i said it uh very excited i
will do it and i will be here for the
podcast on monday oh you're leaving
early yeah the three hurts that hurts
yeah that hurts me yeah that hurts me
i'll be a zombie i'll bring it richmond
virginia the funny bone what june 3rd
and 4th all right i'll do that too
that's a great [ __ ] club omaha
nebraska funny bone come on you know i
love you omaha june 10th and 11th come
get some tickets at
or stickboy.com that's it b that's
everybody this is the final kid we're
out